here is kawhi leonard paul george and
beverly the five for the clippers good
defense inside by davis
pass break and lebron the other way
whoa we put it down hard caldwell
pope but the look ahead here by
schroeder and lebron james
oh he's right there for catches
[Applause]
[Music]
oh westbrook got there
because it looked like it was going to
be a clean look
for levert who played well home court
in that play-in situation
[Music]
they moved to ninth indiana drops to 10
on a night that russell westbrook makes
history
tying oscar robertson
and westbrook gets his second block of
the night
and yes you know we're able to be
entertained by the world's greatest
lebron gives it away sterling brown and
that is blocked by anthony davis on the
other end
i mean i'm all for trying
up and down pace they go derek jones jr
oh
denied by lebron james tucker getting
around the defense and finishing and
then on defense lebron
making that effort you have to love that
35 for bl2 point game matthews with
[Applause]
garrison matthews get that to russell
westbrook put a three
i mean did that just happen
did a good job of recognizing that the
laker bigs were not in position to
contest a shot
a.d the spin of the slam anthony
davis working it inside anthony davis
quits showing
off now you got to make him pay for the
the turnover here lebron will
bring it up oh logo ball he's got it
did they say wesley touched that on the
shot look at this logo three by lebron
boy and it doesn't look like he does
anything extra
to deliver it a lot of players have to
do it turnover off the inbounds
and now anda cupola gets it taken away
westbrook
i mean if you miss you want to leave
time to be able to
commit a foul and lengthen the game
schroeder going all the way
dishes a d throws it down to tyler
no whistle though schroeder sets it up
drives
makes plumley commit spots anthony davis
and
anthony davis glides in for the flush 90
seconds to go in the quarter lakers with
possession of 10.
lebron james closing in on a triple
double kuzma hanks can't finish but
lebron over the top
with a one-handed stuff 36 year old
how many games does this guy play
yeah you know there's going to be some
contact it just doesn't matter he rises
above the
defender and puts it back with the
emphatic jam and you
you see on the video 40 seconds to go
westbrook the hesitation oh monster jam
by russell westbrook and the foul
oh my gosh i mean
dip him in holy water
oh man and he wanted all the action
afterwards i mean look at that
oh it's like it's got to get a little
bit more ball and body movement
what a dish from schroeder and he threw
that one down with authority
notices the real the roll man right
there and
hands it off and anthony davis does the
rash flushes it we've got a
two point kings lead murray tried to
fire
kuzma was right there back on top porter
three and a kuzma rebound quick hitch
down
what a great throw lebron
james hits harrell taking a look at
coast to coast
presented by t-mobile lebron right on
the screws
harold twists and puts it up lebron five
assists seven rebounds 19 points
down by 12 at half time a live update
steph curry's got 25 in the game for
golden state against
boston the lob to westbrook oh wow
[Applause]
i mean great back screen play out of the
timeout look at the hang time
look at that string by lopez right there
probably got away with illegal but it
freed up
it's gonna be jokic he looked to give it
back to rivers now dribbles it out
the pazzo from downtown davis
miraculously
with a closeout that never seemed to
end this is just ridiculous defensively
over the last two years as the closest
offender that guy is number two in the
league
there's a reason why six foot ten
long athletic and unbelievable instincts
look at the ground
covered the stretch out 18 years
professionally
at the highest level
we mentioned that what a pass right
there martin tucker
what a pass he is houdini
in stride bull bull was in
i mean taylon horton tucker
in stride with the easy finish
on point good defense by
beal kept alive but westbrook rips the
rebound down
leaves it for gafford for the big dunk
he just knows where to run to
being in the right place at the right
time and finishing
[Applause]
suns were pesky down the stretch
which was way too much a deep going for
more
[Applause]
nasty
and then this backwards alley-oop dunk
and a foul by devin booker
what else does this man have up his
sleeve today
bounce jackson turnover take it by the
lakers lebron the middle man
lebron with it he's gonna start all the
way
one hand slam dunk lebron little change
of pace
yeah that hesitation dunked by lebron as
he pushed the lakers
up by eight on that play but then the
christians answered back with the deuce
that's some play by lebron levert
to answer no westbrook up ahead
beale oh wow what a play
russ throwing that on the money but i
like what brad did he turned that into a
i'm sure eight would like to have that
over again here's lebron and crowder was
right there for him he knew it was
coming
another laker turnover booker running
the floor a little sidestep oh
denied off the glass well you don't give
up on the play i mean it's
this is you know game three let's see if
they take a rushed
looking three montrez shot and gamer
just about sink for the tie
lebron ties it at 105.
good game where the lakers are going
into o
t second time in a row against the
thunder
half minute left first half
there's lead on the drive and put home
by westbrook
remaining of the first half foul goes on
alex and westbrook
just beautiful anticipation
tip tip dunk right there goes up with
authority
and smacks his teammate for good measure
in the head
the lakers haven't guarded many people
alan shooters lost it they guarded
someone there three on two
james through the lane the shovel back
to davis
beautiful feed james to david
and you see the steel there while kyle
cough and lebron james with the slow
transition
robin lopez
[Music]
russell with lopez over embiid and
russell westbrook on the follow his end
of the bargain hasn't he oh yeah he's
getting it down as we see rush right
here get it done catching that lob but
bradley bill has 17 points
schroeder who's had a quiet night
himself two points one of four from the
floor
james look the tomahawk
throw down from lebron james
watch this and look just throws a needle
between two defenders and puts a little
extra on it
[Applause]
maine
and the laker bench look at that they're
they're having so much fun
[Applause]
westbrook for the lead hachimaran
what a way to get your first basket of
the night
how about this put back here by russell
westbrook been struggling from the field
but it doesn't get none easier than that
nicole jokic
nails it james drives down a lane goes
up
and throws it down how does that
happen a don't down the other end you
know what that is then lebron splitting
the double team
and then just takes off they aren't a
one-two punch
anthony edwards no timberwolves seven
o'clock how about that pass
it was a nice outlet by lebron
at the stripe 92 free throw shooter
[Music]
[Applause]
he's 36 and he looks like he's on that
cover of si that you were
showing a couple minutes ago reggie but
hold on look at
kevin durant on the brooklyn bench
morris puts it in lebron james now
westbrook
guarding lebron westbrook trying to stay
with him and lebron james is fouled and
count the basket switches on to lebron
james and
fouls him here and lebron able to score
man oh man huge i don't like
i don't like that switch for washington
i'm not throwing out other teams in the
western conference fully healthy
there's a bunch of very good teams that
have a chance and i believe that this
utah
that's how you shut up and announce he's
26.
get out of the way finds jones oh good
pass to hood
kuzma goes by him hood can't knock down
the three it's been a struggle for hood
career low and scoring and three-point
shooting great look down for it
and it spins home for montrez harrell to
pull la within four
and what you're not seeing here from
this pass and great just right straight
up
great pass and great finish but prior to
this there was a
sixth place lakers have time here's
james with four
lebron with two lets it fly and hits
at the buzzer 73 first half points a
season high for the lakers
and lebron james just taking his time he
knows he has plenty of time and just
pulls
up from deep knocks it down
just adding three more points to this
already monstrous lead by the los
angeles lakers
kick it out wide open three they don't
get it rebound lebron
long lead for kuzma got it touchdown
pass
more bench points tonight for the lakers
one point lead
time now to check in with the exit you
know lakers in a string of three
straight
games seeing the top three picks in the
draft
james all the way reverse slayer of the
circus shot for lebron
get that play where lebron had it they
had him and then both defenders leave
him
then he makes the up and timber wolves
will
bring it up slowly they have the fast
break advantage so far in this game 14-9
layman oh
blocked by james lebron james was that a
block or did it hit the front of the rim
look at this again layman he goes up
through the dunk
blocked by james so who who touches it
last was the key
here they come it's one on four so
graham did the smart thing
but the quickness now rolls here blocked
by james
as he came over to block it from rozier
you might beat me with the first step
but you better be able to finish
up here i come and there it goes
you know there's the yardstick that i
like to use for the lakers when kcp is
involved and active offensively this
laker team can be very tough
schroeder the love throw it down king
15 11. what a play
by lebron james and that forces a
timeout
with the lakers up by four
so lebron in the lakers looking for win
number 42
on the air and 21 on the road all behind
the back to caruso
how do you do really pretty look at him
surveying it
james two defenders on him to caldwell
pope inside he's tied up by green
throws it back up top james puts up the
three oh it's
gone lebron james from downtown
as the shot clock expires
[Applause]
it's a big time shot awful execution
realizes that the clock dwindling down
the good chase down by curry and
lebron elevates and knocks down the
biggest shot of the night that's a
30-footer and you see curry
who's had that look on opponent's faces
after he knocks down
threes the same look as lebron james
with a clutch
shot each team has had a lead here comes
booker
locked away by james another turnover by
phoenix and pesky defense here they go
lefron crowbars it in fingers on top by
two the captivating play by lebron
james hammers it home for the waker this
has become personal between these two
cleared out lebron wants crowder
shot clock to seven spins off of him
lebron hangs the reverse is good and
look at the laker bench
craig the former nugget who was acquired
from the bucks early this season
macklemore three-pointers good about
that pass from lebron
well james got hung up in the air and
made
something great out of nothing ben
mclemore
sticks to three that's three points made
up
off of a call that should have been made
amen oh james amen on that but spinning
on the slam
now the lakers go up by nine playing
well
great left to right spin by james and
his sprint down the court
was even better a mouth a gate
we don't see that often crowder misses
the three
james stolen by payne james gets it back
caruso
up to james for the slam what a wild
play
and the lakers go back up by four lebron
james has it
in his tank russo doesn't make this play
a couple of weeks ago
but he trusts that lebron james has the
ability
the athleticism and the health to go get
it off the backboard
absolutely beautiful turning back time